Bonjour à toutes et à tous
et bienvenue dans ce nouveau podcast
alors aujourd'hui on est à l'extérieur
il fait beau il fait chaud mais il fait un peu frais
donc j'ai mis un pull
aujourd'hui dans ce nouveau podcast
je voulais vous parler du métier de ma femme
alors l'année dernière on est parti un an au Japon
en voyage une année sabbatique une année de pause
et en fait
on s'est dit que quand on allait rentrer en France
on voulait essayer
de nouveaux métiers
pour ma part je suis devenu professeur de français
c'est-à-dire que je donne des cours de
de français individuels sur la plateforme preply
et je fais aussi ce contenu
cette création de contenu
sur YouTube sur Instagram
sur TikTok
et ma femme
elle a choisi de devenir artiste
et je voulais vous parler de ce métier aujourd'hui
alors ça fait longtemps qu'elle dessine
notamment des dessins digitaux
donc de l'art digital
elle dessine grâce à une tablette numérique
des dessins qu'elle poste ensuite sur Instagram
et en fait avant même de partir au Japon
ses dessins étaient assez populaires sur Instagram
il me semble que bon avant le Japon elle avait déjà
peut-être 16 ou 17 000 abonnés sur Instagram
et du coup
tout au long de l'année au Japon
son nombre d'abonnés a augmenté
je crois que maintenant elle doit être
autour de 47 000
avant ça elle faisait un métier qui ne lui
plaisait pas forcément
on ne fait pas forcément un métier qui nous plaît
mais du coup quand on était au Japon
que j'ai décidé de changer de métier
elle s'est dit pourquoi pas
moi aussi essayer quelque chose de nouveau
on a 30 ans on va rentrer en France et on aura rien
aucune charge on n'a pas de crédit pour
acheter une maison
on n'a pas d'enfant donc
c'est sûrement le meilleur moment pour essayer
des nouvelles aventures
de nouveaux métiers
je suis devenu professeur de français
et elle a décidé de devenir artiste
d'essayer de vivre de son art
alors quand on pense
quand on réfléchit à son nombre d'abonnés
on peut se dire
ah bah elle doit déjà gagner de l'argent
elle doit faire de la publicité etc ...
mais je pense que pour les
artistes
c'est différent et c'est sûrement plus difficile
de pouvoir vivre de son art
il y a cette distinction
je pense entre l'artiste et
l'aspect commercial qu'on peut avoir
quand on fait ce genre de métier
c'est-à-dire que parfois il y a des très bons artistes
mais qui ont du mal à se mettre en avant
et à l'inverse
parfois il y a des artistes qui ne
sont pas forcément les meilleurs
ou qui ne sont pas forcément
hyper talentueux ou excellents dans leur domaine
mais qui arrivent à se faire une place
parce que
ce sont de bons commerciaux ou de bons
de bons
ils sont bons en marketing etc ...
on a ça par exemple avec la musique
où parfois il y a des artistes
qui savent très bien se mettre en avant
qui savent très bien se vendre
et qui arrivent à percer dans le monde de la musique
à avoir une carrière en tant que musicien
grâce à ces compétences là
et du coup
le passage
d'être un artiste à essayer de vivre de son art
il n'est pas du tout évident
il n'est pas facile
et c'est même plutôt difficile je pense
parce que là où on prend beaucoup de plaisir à créer
quelque chose
à faire du dessin de la musique etc
avoir une carrière dans ce domaine artistique
c'est beaucoup plus compliqué
et ça c'est du coup ce que
ce que est en train d'essayer de faire ma femme
c'est-à-dire qu'elle est en train d'essayer
de développer sa carrière artistique
pour pouvoir gagner
de l'argent
grâce à son art
pour qu'elle puisse vivre de son art
et pour ça il y a il y a plusieurs façons de faire
la première c'est via les réseaux sociaux d'avoir un modèle
influenceur on va dire
c'est-à-dire que vous produisez du contenu
vous avez beaucoup de visibilité
et du coup ensuite vous avez un format
un business modèle
autour de la publicité
des marques vont vous contacter pour vendre
pour mettre en avant leurs produits
et vous allez être payés grâce à ces publicités
ça c'est le format très classique d'un influenceur
il me semble que les influenceurs français
par exemple les plus connus
c'est des milliers d'euros pour faire une story
sur un produit ou un post
et du coup c'est quelque chose qui
si on arrive à créer une communauté
à avoir beaucoup de followers
peut-être très rentable
enfin on on peut gagner beaucoup d'argent
désolé c'est mon père qui est passé juste là
donc je reprends
ça peut être, ça peut être
ça peut faire gagner beaucoup d'argent
d'avoir une très grosse communauté
et voilà de
d'avoir ce format publicitaire
et je pense que quelqu'un comme
Kim Kardashian par exemple
se porte très bien
et qu'elle n'a pas de problème d'argent
donc ça c'est le modèle publicitaire
et après mais dans le cadre de l'art
c'est assez difficile parce qu'on met en avant nos
on va mettre en avant notre art
enfin les artistes vont mettre en avant leur
leur art
et
ce n'est pas forcément
un contenu qui est très engageant
c'est pas c'est pas comme quelqu'un qui se met en avant
quand quelqu'un se met en avant
quand un influenceur se met en avant
il est facile de de s'imaginer voilà
être ami avec cette personne
et on va avoir tout ce qu'on appelle le parasocial
c'est-à-dire que les personnes qui suivent
un influenceur
vont avoir
l'impression de bien connaître cette personne
alors que l'inverse n'est pas du tout vrai
donc quand on est artiste
ça c'est très difficile parce que
réussir à créer une communauté autour de
juste de l'art
c'est très compliqué
et du coup il y a un
un autre moyen de gagner sa vie
c'est en vendant des produits
en vendant du merchandising ou en vendant
des illustrations
des peintures
quand on réfléchit voilà
on s'imagine que un peintre il va faire une peinture
qui va la vendre
et qui va gagner sa vie comme ça
sauf que bon déjà
réussir à faire une œuvre c'est compliqué
ça prend beaucoup de temps
mais ensuite ça veut dire que pour que ce soit viable
économiquement
il faudrait que les
que ce peintre
cet artiste vendent beaucoup
de peinture ou vendre très cher une peinture
c'est pareil pour la musique
quand vous faites de la musique maintenant
vous avez plusieurs sources de revenus
soit vous vendez des disques
soit vous faites beaucoup de stream
on va vous rémunérer
au nombre de stream que vous faites
sur Spotify par exemple
et après il y a toute la partie concert
où les gens vont payer pour venir vous voir en concert
et du coup
vous allez gagner de l'argent par ce biais-là
donc ma femme
ce qu'elle a décidé
c'est d'essayer de vivre de son art
via de la vente de petits produits
via la vente de de petites illustrations
de petits porte-clés ce genre de chose
et ça par deux moyens
le premier c'est la création d'un site e-commerce
sur lequel elle vend ses créations
vous pouvez aller sur le site
vous pouvez acheter des produits
et ensuite elle les envoie
et comme ça elle arrive à générer de l'argent
à gagner de l'argent pour pouvoir vivre
et la deuxième partie
c'est un peu la même chose mais c'est là en convention
ce qu'elle fait ça a une dimension assez japonaise
et en France il y a beaucoup de conventions
autour de la culture japonaise
la plus grande c'est la Japan Expo à Paris
je sais plus exactement mais il me semble que c'est
que c'est peut-être
100.000 personnes ou plus sur 4 jours
dans un lieu fait pour ça
où en fait vous vous arrivez dans la convention
et il y a plein de stands de créateurs
il y a plein de stands d'entreprise comme Nintendo
ou d'autres où vous pouvez essayer des produits
où il y a des activités
où vous pouvez acheter des
des petites œuvres d'art à des artistes etc
et du coup là
ce que ma femme essaie de faire c'est de développer
les produits qu'elle peut vendre à partir de son art
à partir de ses dessins
tout ce qu'elle vend
est créé à partir de son art
pour ensuite les vendre soit sur internet
soit dans la vraie vie entre guillemets
dans des conventions
et d'ailleurs ce weekend
on va à une convention à Bordeaux
et le weekend d'après on part à Bruxelles
en Belgique faire une autre convention
pardon mais
je pense que je sortirai ce podcast entre les deux
j'enregistre un peu à l'avance
et du coup voilà c'est c'est ça qu'elle est
qu'elle est en train d'essayer de faire
c'est-à-dire qu'elle continue de dessiner
elle continue de prendre du plaisir à créer
mais derrière il faut qu'elle réussisse à vendre
des choses en lien avec son art
à commercialiser entre guillemets son art
pour pouvoir en vivre
pour pouvoir tous les mois
recevoir de l'argent et pouvoir
payer le loyer
payer les courses etc
en sachant que moi aussi du coup
mon salaire est peut-être plus instable
étant donné que j'ai tout démarré de zéro
pour mes cours de français
donc voilà à peu près
je voulais
parler de ça parce que je trouvais ça intéressant
ce n'est
c'est une dimension qu'on a du mal à avoir
quand on est en dehors de tout ce
ce monde artistique
c'est-à-dire que
quand on n'est pas forcément très familier avec l'art
on va se dire bon bah
soit tu es un peintre reconnu
mondialement reconnu et tu vas vendre une toile
une peinture à des milliers voir des millions d'euros
et ce sera bon comme ça
mais je pense que voilà il y a beaucoup d'artistes
de petits artistes qui sont
qui ne sont pas du tout dans ce cette dynamique-là
et je pense que c'est pareil avec la musique
vous avez plein de groupes de musique
qui font quelques streams sur les
les plateformes de streaming
qui arrivent à générer un petit revenu
mais qui derrière aussi
réussissent à gagner leur vie via leur tournée
via leur concert
via le via les tickets qu'ils peuvent vendre
via le merchandising hein, des t-shirts
des CD des vinyles etc
et donc je
je trouve ça intéressant de se mettre un peu dans cette
peau là de se mettre à la place de ces personnes
pour voir un peu la difficulté que c'est
de d'être artiste
je pense que, on peut d'un point de vue extérieur
on peut avoir l'impression que être artiste
c'est faire ce qu'on veut ce qu'on aime
sans trop se poser
de questions pardon
alors que c'est plutôt l'inverse
c'est qu'il faut réussir à
avoir une dimension commerciale
sur quelque chose qu'on aime faire
et du coup parfois c'est assez difficile
on a facilement je pense
ce dilemme
entre faire quelque chose qui nous plaît à 100%
et faire quelque chose qu'on pense pouvoir
vendre facilement ou vendre plus facilement
typiquement si vous faites de la musique
vous allez-vous dire
soit je fais un truc hyper spécifique
je compose une musique hyper spécifique
qui correspond vraiment à ce que j'aime
ou je vais essayer de faire quelque chose de plus
commercial une musique plus mainstream
parce que je pense que ça va plaire à plus de monde
et ça bon c'est le dilemme
éternel je pense des artistes c'est-à-dire
qu'est-ce que je veux vraiment faire
et comment je peux gagner ma vie
donc voilà ce sont les questions
auxquelles ma femme essaie de répondre cette année
je l'aide je suis l'assistant sur les conventions
je l'aide à mettre en place
le stand
et à vendre avec elle toute la journée
parce que c'est assez épuisant
il y a beaucoup de monde
on est constamment en train de parler
on est souvent debout
donc je l'aide pour ça
et donc là on va aller à Bordeaux puis à Bruxelles
et je vais voir d'ailleurs
si je peux pas faire une sorte de petit vlog où
je filme voilà
plusieurs étapes de
de ces aventures-là
voilà donc
vendredi on part pour Bordeaux
j'essaierai de filmer quelques trucs
pour vous faire une petite vidéo un peu style vlog
je pense que ça peut être sympa
dans ce format pour vous faire pratiquer le français
et désolé
parce qu'il y a beaucoup de voitures qui passent
si vous aimez ce format
n'hésitez pas à me le dire en commentaire
ce n'est pas du tout écrit
donc ça peut être un peu brouillon
mais je pense que
c'est plus naturel et que du coup ça sera plus facile
ça va vous aider à comprendre plus facilement
les français natifs
et voilà n'hésitez pas à vous abonner
à laisser un like sur la vidéo
en ce moment les
les performances des des vidéos sont plutôt bonnes
donc merci pour votre
pour votre soutien
et je vous dis à la prochaine du coup